[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live more cognito
here at illinois podcast
launchinggaming.net
and who is this fine gentleman we have
in the realm of facts today hi my name
is luis lamia i work here at five
o'clock games nice 505 in the building
i'm really here to talk about a game
real experience rogue spirits let's talk
about it let's get into it man tell us
about rogue spirit for anyone that
doesn't know anything about this game
what's rogue's word about
royal experience currently in early
access and you play as the spirit of
this prince who has lost their kingdom
okay they really want it back and they
want to get sort of like the redemption
story
uh if you see behind this menu right
here you see all the characters you can
possess right now okay okay that's right
but it isn't early access right now so
we're adding more characters as time
goes on nice but essentially that's the
main mechanic you're the spirit who can
embody the bodies of other warriors
archers soldiers
uh various types of
characters
and with them come new abilities powers
that's our sort of like roguelike
mechanic so we got the roguelike
mechanic going on i'm already feeling
the art style and loving who this
character is with the stack
this is really really cool so you're
going for the roblox aspect so right now
kind of started off in an initial
town setting getting the story going on
now do you know like as far as some
people who are
kind of new to roblox like would this be
a good start for them like how why would
this game help someone
really try to get into the genre for the
first time there's a lot of people
struggling with these genres sometimes
yeah i think it offers enough hand
holding to
lead you down the correct path of where
you need to do but still giving you
enough freedom to experiment level up
the characters that you want to play as
you know we give you the option but we
don't force you down any specific
character nice
that is really cool attic right now
in the training guppies
doing the training doing the secondary
attack
okay
i guess we have to do a secondary attack
again
offensive defense we're giving you the a
little quick run down to the mechanics
showing you everything
you got
a mechanic run down very cool
oh but you did mention the art style yes
i'm a huge fan of it as well i love like
the vibrant colors
it's a little bit animated so it gives
that nice little vibrant color aspect to
it it extremely attracts it to me to me
as well it's like that a little anime
but very vibrant yeah and the animation
is really subtle and cool and i don't
know if you know this or i figured it
maybe it's based on the unity engine or
things like that but whatever it is
it's really pleasant aesthetically
pleasing
this is our take on it we wanted to do
something really interesting with it and
that's the part that's actually really
refreshing about it you love to see a
different take so we're going on we're
still doing our tutorials still doing
the stuff in the tutorial here grand
master possessing the bodies okay
oh okay this is the spirit [ __ ] oh
there you go now you got two swords you
got your two sword style mask okay
grand master
give me your stones
so we got our elemental resistor we got
some skill masks we have range masking
so again
looking like you can spec out you can
kind of
get into a play style that you like what
else can you tell us about kind of like
this type of system that seems to be
going on at roadster so we have like our
established classes and types of
characters which everyone will have but
how you progress and how you level up is
ultimately what makes your character
your own
some people might have like one
character they really like and they'll
completely work towards putting that
character to the max
some might have a variety of them from
our time here at pax a lot of people
range between like close combat or they
prefer the archers that's like more
uh far range combat nice no i'm noticing
now here's the thing
anyone you kill is it a situation where
you can then get the possessive one or
the specific
people that you only specific are
characters or entities that you could
get into their spirit i believe it's
entities that have the same class type
so yeah that's like the characters kind
of look like you right that's how you
can tell them apart got you so i noticed
there's a stealth mechanic in this game
you can see where they're looking here
yeah you can you can completely avoid
them if you go around
you get more damage if you actually hit
the behind exactly exactly
you're catching on quite well
got the little cones going okay
he's been a fan favorite for how much
power he got
nice this is cool though continuing
going on in the tent
and having another possessing other
people opens up broader play styles
exactly exactly offer some
experimentation to find your own footing
maybe you like a combination maybe you
like one specific i like them we try not
to force you into anything but we want
to give you the freedom to do without i
like this range it's actually giving me
kuna mitsu vibes attacking with a bone i
like that
i'm trying to see what some of the
inspirations are because like a lot of
cool mythos it seems a lot of cool
different things
implemented into it and it just i just
love the way the design and the style of
the characters are
yeah i think a lot of it was just
inspired by like really cool artwork and
animation that offers that really
colorful vibrant art style yes and
typically not something you really see
in rogue bikes
usually i mean at least from just about
the last few years it's very 2d style or
it's very like not as vibrant or
colorful yep as we talked about
absolutely yeah man
the characters that you're going against
right
so
like is there any preference to like the
same person it's like one might be
stronger than the other like if you're
the same let's say you meet up with
another go person and you want to
translate their body just could it be
that that one is stronger than the one
you've already possessed it's more or
less just open to how you want to play
okay like i've heard a lot of people
were like oh i can't really get the feel
for the archery like i'm not really good
at aiming so i'd rather do close combat
right
would he have been stronger than the
other
i believe it's just the same art thing
to whatever like gotcha
so just out of curiosity
it's better for you to possess certain
enemies to fight other enemies oh it
ultimately just depends if you are more
preferencing like close combat or rather
long range
it's really just up to the player
once you find that style you like then
you can kind of spec into it you can
kind of
kind of more kind of be more gradual
with a lot of the um like so for example
the range character right if you if you
like that style
can you expect more into it can you do
more things with it as far as raising
attributes and things of that nature
yeah aren't that cool
that's pretty awesome it's pretty
awesome
and then this is our 0.9 update okay but
uh we're adding more characters i
believe this update added two characters
in a boss battle
and it's another access right now but
we're going to be out of early access on
our 1.0 update on june 10th nice nice
early access
what's that attic what you like a little
chain drink what you like
it's got lightning
i believe
yeah this is my style right here with
the staff i like that um i'm a personal
favorite of like the close combat nymph
yeah yeah that's the thing yeah that's
my thing right there
so again i know early access right now
but from a platform standpoint you know
is this something that you plan on and
get in the castle where are we looking
for rooms for it to be out you know
early at this stage for the time being
we're on early access in steam so for
those watching at home you can go ahead
and just get this on steam right now
right now steve um but we are getting
feedback and we're listening oh okay
well we like you listening listening is
good because that means ultimately
so some of my console brethren
might be very interested in this style
of game so this is definitely something
to keep an eye out on there on that
front control crossover
and i know it's the starting point that
pull can you also at that starting point
pick
make the choices i guess my question
also is like when can you switch what
are the specific key moments when you
can switch out
i believe this is just like the
introduction so it kind of guides you
with this character i'll take action it
opens up and you can start experimenting
pretty quickly
okay your thoughts on the attic it's
interesting it's interesting to like
take something body after you've killed
them you never had a game like that yeah
it's not it's a unique material and i've
noticed if you went if you try to come
out and fight like someone that has fire
she had eyes so i'm weak to her shoes
yeah they have some sort of resistance
it's pretty cool man
and it's a different play style it's
very very unique in that respect it
almost reminds me of a wrong spirit and
nobody meets the world save the world
kind of thing with all these
varied play styles yeah we really wanted
to incorporate the roguelike mechanic to
the narrative and it's not just like
he's changing for the sake of because
the game player dictates it too but
there's like a story behind it it is the
spirit there is a narrative behind it
well that that is very interesting
because we definitely want to i
definitely enjoy games that are very
narrative driven and the fact that you
guys are actually going for that in the
game
is pretty cool too and i don't i know
obviously it's early access because it's
too much but is there a plan for any
type of maybe
cinematic storytelling or you know voice
acting or even during the game you know
dialogue like how would you know what
how the story may be conveyed if
possible you can give us that we don't
have anything to announce just yet we
basically have like the foundation at
the moment
this sort of introduction area doesn't
really show off too much
uh but it's more meant to just give you
a guide for the mechanics and let you
actually get a taste of it
man we are very promising
definitely feeling what i'm saying right
now i think addict is in so we
definitely got to keep our honest
attitude any other closing thoughts on
rogue spirits early access five
okay
you get busy with the wolverine clothes
okay now what did
yeah they go into your your rpg
progression system gotcha
that is cool
let's see if we'll see if that could get
to a box before you die
he's doing really well something what
he's doing he's detecting
living you living
oh we got someone coming out yeah
oh yeah nice spooky commentator's curse
getting spooky
you trying to grab somebody
okay still surviving
only got that five hp though
and how can he get his house look at
these things he could do together
okay so shawn's on the team okay
still searching we're still scouring
let's see what we can do
might guide me towards the boss
i'm close with you to a boss i think you
might be able to jump through that
bridge area okay
this one right here
you jump to that
place
possibly backtracking that okay
see if we can get that i'll be cool if
we can see that
they're going after you they got the
patrols on here boy they are serious
with it but usually if you if you go
towards where the monsters are they will
guide you
another one right there see if we can
get to it
yeah
the more damage you take the more your
outside skill starts
like this it's really deteriorating
exactly exactly it's really really nice
portal's always very bossy
level completed
nice
and again so this is like a
okay
trying to figure so what what is this
area here like that oh there's just like
another level that we're going on here
does this allow you to like swap to a
different body if you wanted to then
it's like a good way to get your health
back before you're like jumping into
this
okay
like a little breather a little breather
before the drama
i like how it has like a little
randomness in here because these are
eyes gonna change it
yeah we try to sprinkle it in often
enough that you feel like you're not
just fighting and not progressing
anywhere that there's something
happening and you are working towards
something
oh no
it's going down
still surgery still searching
nice
i guess you could also see two three
showcase of the environment and like the
aesthetic of how the village is made in
the day and night cycle yeah
you start you start to see it especially
with the lighting you know
also like with the rooms are like the
light source it kind of points up to the
ceiling to give your indications so we
didn't make it to the boss
we got a lot in
again rogue spirit early access right
now yeah right so for those who are
interested those who want to support it
you know where could they go to find out
access besides access their like discord
any other information about the game
they can find out about you can join the
505 games discord we have access to this
as well as all our various other games
that we have published and still coming
out soon awesome man best way to get
into contact with us nice 505's in the
building roadster an absolute pleasure
to have you in the realm thank you very
much thanks for coming thanks for
playing check it out man again early
action supporter if you're with a very
unique title
[Music]
you